all right we're gonna move on to five
headlines
[Music]
quick tip here folks if i'm ever in
possession of some kind of
important information and uh you need to
torture me
to get it out of me which i'd prefer if
you didn't
but if you needed to here's how to do it
this is the torture method that would
cause me to crack and tell you
everything i know within like five
minutes
tops okay right here the daily wire
reports on august 1st hbo sports will
air
seeing america with megan rapinoe the
conversation featuring rapido
the u.s women's national soccer team
captain representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez
1619 project creator nicole hannah jones
and comedia hassan minaj
this is this is my hell this is
literally my hell dear god
horrifying better not to dwell on it
let's move on to number two
warner brothers media this is also from
the daily wire is investigating
the ellen degeneres show amid
accusations of workplace abuse according
to variety executives from telepictures
which produces ellen's show and
distributor warren brothers warner
brothers
television sent a memo to staffers last
week announcing warner media's employees
relations division
and a third-party firm will be
interviewing current and former staffers
about their experience working on the
show
as the daily wire reported earlier this
month buzzfeed interviewed several
former employees of the show
who claimed they experienced a toxic
work environment counter to ellen's
image as a kind-hearted person
so um so there's been stories for years
about ellen degeneres being basically a
terrible person
who treats her subordinates like garbage
uh i've known this for a long time
and uh i'm not in the know at all and
i i don't follow celebrity celebrity
gossip very closely
but even i had heard this so if i heard
about this
it's hard to believe that warner media
is just now finding out
they aren't of course it's just that
everyone else is finding out it's it's
officially becoming common knowledge and
that means that they have to pretend to
do something
they have to pretend to care if you
haven't read the accusations against
ellen
uh you can find them anywhere online
it's just what i said i mean she treats
allegedly the people around her like
utter crap
all the time and as a diva on steroids
as the accusation goes
um some people find this this surprising
about ellen
and i i can't really see why you'd be
surprised is it because
her brand on television is that of a
friendly lovable person
is it because she brings people on the
show to perform acts of charity for
them in front of a live studio audience
you know she brings a
whatever a kid is goes viral with some
cute video and then she brings the kid
on and interviews them and then
gives them a bunch of toys you know in
front of everybody um
is that did anyone really think that
that that that reflects her character
that proves that she's a
oh yes you're performing charity
in front of an audience that that's
clapping for you i mean
you're literally getting a standing
ovation live on the set
as you perform an act of charity it's
it's it's
it's nice it's good for the person who's
receiving the charity i feel good for
the kid that gets all the toys and all
that kind of stuff but
it doesn't tell me anything about you at
all um
none of that even remotely tells us
about your character
just because someone's nice on tv tv
with cameras rolling doesn't mean that
they're a good person once the light
switch is off obviously
really if you if you want to find one
indicator one thing
that tells you everything you need to
know about a person's character
it's it's obviously not how they act
when the camera's on it's also not how
they treat their friends
or anything like that everybody's nice
to their friends that's the whole point
that's why they're your friends
it's how they treat people who they can
get away with
abusing so ellen can't get away with
heaping abuse on people on tv nor should
can she really do it to her fellow
celebrities people who are on her level
but she can and did apparently direct
this abuse to people beneath her you
know
interns staff etc um and everyone no
matter who you are what position you
have there are people below you on the
totem pole at least in some situations
i mean all of us no matter how powerless
we are
usually like there are situations
throughout the day that we're in
where we have some kind of power over
another person
and if you are
an a-hole in those situations
even if it only happens briefly right
if you're an a-hole in those situations
then you're just a terrible person
if you take advantage of those power
dynamics to be the a-hole you can be
you're an awful person down the board
and we know that about you because it
doesn't matter how you
act towards your friends or how generous
or nice you are to them all that matters
as far as assessing someone's character
all that matters is how they act towards
the people
they can get away with treating poorly
that's all that matters and i was
actually thinking about this when i was
um at the dmv last week because you know
at
dmv is a perfect example of this at the
dmv
uh is someone you know there's the woman
sitting in the booth
booth uh the boof sure there's the woman
sitting in the booth
across from you and you're doing
whatever changing registrations getting
a license whatever it is
she has enormous power over you in
in that situation now as soon as you
leave she doesn't really but
when you're sitting there she's got a
she has you in her
grasp and if she wants to make your life
miserable she can do it and the reason
people hate the dmv is that some dmv
employees
enjoy taking advantage of that power
dynamic of that momentary grasp they
have on you
and do they do exactly that they just
make your life miserable for no apparent
reason
but i was thinking about this because
the woman that i was dealing with
at the dmv last week was the opposite
she was super friendly and kind
and was uh was trying to help me so that
the dmv process was as painless as
possible you know
and uh i thought to myself wow this is a
very good person i
i'm interacting with her for a few
minutes i don't know anything about her
don't even know her name i i could tell
you this is a good person 100
just because of of this right here she
doesn't have to
be this nice but she is
so um that's how you can assess people's
character and that's why
in conclusion ellen degeneres is
terrible number three
nick sandman the covington catholic
student who was slandered all over the
media reached a settlement in his
defamation suit against the washington
post this week
this after reaching a settlement with
cnn a few months ago
but cnn is not done defaming him it
seems brian stelter cnn anchor
retweeted a tweet from a lawyer named
mark zaid
and the tweet said um those with zero
legal experience as far as i can tell
should not be conjecturing on lawsuits
they know nothing about
what kind of journalism is that i've
litigated defamation suits
defamation cases sandman was undoubtedly
paid nuisance value settlement and
nothing more well
so stelder didn't say that but he did
retweet it and salmon's lawyer lynn wood
says that this could easily breach cnn's
confidentiality agreement because they
aren't allowed to discuss the terms
of the settlement yet here's stelter
maybe i guess he would argue not
discussing it but but
uh amplifying someone who is
and discussing it through a proxy in
effect and wood indicates that
that it's he's lying anyway uh that the
claim isn't true
so they're just
you can only imagine how angry
these the people at washington post and
cnn are
um and how much they hate this kid
how much they absolutely hate him they
are they are
overcome with hate because they're not
used to this
this isn't how it's supposed to go they
slander and defame people all the time
especially speaking of power dynamics
especially focusing on people
don't have any power to fight back and
they thought that's what they were doing
here
you know they consider it from
from from their perspective you know you
almost feel sorry for them well not
really but
they've been doing this for so long just
defaming people it doesn't matter
painting people as racist just you know
just destroying people's life
casually like it's nothing and um
and all of a sudden out of nowhere
they figure okay well you know here
we've got a case just a bunch of high
school kids white high school kids
we could do this to them well you know
no big deal we'll destroy their lives
get some clicks out of it
uh virtue signal a little bit their
lives are destroyed we move on
this is the process this is what we do
and then nick sandman comes out of
nowhere and actually fights back
and wins these these poor people at cnn
and washington post
they're really the victims here they're
the victims because they weren't able to
victimize someone else or at least they
victimized someone else and uh
and then they got they got hit back in
the nose number four
an aclu lawyer named chase strangio has
uh
accused j.k rowling of contributing to
genocide
by arguing that uh because you know jk
rowling has
argued that biological sex exists that
that's really her
entire argument um she's not even
despite what we hear now
she she is far from a conservative on
gender issues or on any issue at all
the only thing she has said on
when it comes to transgenderism that the
left doesn't like is just that
biological sex exists
but that's of course enough to make her
um
not just evil but genocidal so chase
strangio has said that
she is contributing to genocide let me
read let me read this diatribe from uh
strangio this is what it says okay
this is part of it anyway it would be
nice to ignore the harry potter person
but the rhetoric being used on her
massive platform
is feeding a genocidal impulse that
already exists in government and within
individuals
she is dangerous situating the trans
subject and the trans body in the
contested discursive space the way she
does
pulls the conversation around transness
into the posture
of working to locate the legitimate
trans subject
did you get that okay uh the i the idea
being that we must defend against the
allegation that too many trans people in
the world reflects a problem that is
after all her point
and in so doing we see the conversation
to cis people and institutions
and perhaps most insidiously in so doing
we give the false impression that sexed
bodies
are things only trans people have by
obscuring the larger structural impulses
behind
bodily policing and the violence of the
sex binary we ensure that
the continuation of these structures
okay now
first of all there is no genocide of
trans people happening
that should go without saying this
person is making that up
uh i mean unless you count the treatment
of lgbt people
in in muslim countries if that's what
we're talking about
then all right maybe you've got a case
but something tells me that ole strangio
here
is not intending for this to be uniquely
a criticism of muslim societies
or a criticism of muslim societies at
all
something tells me in fact that as far
as this person is concerned we would
just
when talking about the plight of lgbt
people in the world we would just skip
over muslim countries entirely and focus
completely on what's happening in the
west
but in any case genocide or not
defending biology does not amount to
genocide or contribute to it or feed it
okay but really i want you to focus on
the ridiculous lengths this person is
going
to make the anti-science position seem
intelligent and scholarly situating the
trans subject and the trans body in the
contested discursive space
the way she does pulls the conversation
around transits into posturing
into the posture of working to locate
the legitimate trans subject
that sentence uses about 30 words and
loads of jargon to communicate something
that could be conveyed simply in about
10 words
and and and and don't be fooled by this
okay this is the mark of an
of an unintelligent person who wants to
seem intelligent
truly intelligent people who have
legitimate points to make
make them in ways that are clear and
easy to understand
that's what a really intelligent a
really intelligent person
can understand jargony
concepts okay that's that's one level of
intelligence is to understand what's
being said
the next level real intelligence is
being able to convey and communicate it
stripped of the jargon in a
straightforward simple way
if you can't do that then it tells me
you're not really that smart or it tells
me you're a pompous ass
who is who who maybe could be more clear
but you're being
unclear intentionally to show off your
intelligence so either way um either way
it's it's you know in this case it's
kind of a defense mechanism
uh because okay and it works
right i have to have to hand it to them
in a way it works
because they use a lot of academic
jargon
especially when it comes to the gender
ideology on the left
all in service of the claim that men can
have babies
essentially all of this everything you
just heard
is in service to the claim that a man
can get pregnant
which is to call that a dumb position
would be an insult to stupidity
this this is a delusional insane
position
but they trick some people into thinking
that their position is smart and
sciencey
just by putting in a lot of scholarly
jargon and all of that
number five finally here's the san
francisco weekly i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna give you their
the caption um it says surfing
surfing despite its roots in indigenous
pacific islander history
has been seen as a sport for straight
white men for far too long
okay so now surfing is racist too just
just wanted to update you on that
surfing is racist um and i just want to
say about that
to be clear okay
i agree and i think we need to repeal
the laws
prohibiting non-white people from buying
surfboards and going to the ocean
i i didn't know that law existed
if it does i say it's it's 20 20.
let's get rid of it i will take that
stand right now so thank you to the san
francisco weekly
we are we are together in this movement
um and that's your five headlines
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated